welcome I hope you guys are doing okay
sheltering in place if you're new to
what we're doing we're talking about
typography today a bunch of our students
are enrolled in this class and we're
gonna critique their work
this is week five of seven so we will
have two weeks left this week it's any
point size in any weight and joining me
as always is miss mill Cobra team and
she's going to be writing or drawing on
top of some of your submitted layouts
but we'll see how that goes will will
cut back and forth I think some of you
guys are our direct messaging Milka and
telling her that she's like an awesome
human being which she is totally get the
vibes thankfully you're the saving me
from some of the messages so I'm glad
that milk is helping to shoulder some of
that weight and she's very thoughtful in
her responses way more thoughtful than
my to word answers so you're gonna get a
little bit more from Milka than you will
if you send it to me okay so we're gonna
get into the layouts and know how are
you doing today by the way they're good
good I'm excited about this week and I
want to share my acknowledgement that
how this week might have been some one
of the most difficult week of doing
these exercises why because you have
more parameters you have different sizes
and different weights but the exciting
part about it is that using these
different parameters now you can create
great depth so let's dig into it okay
now you and I both have had a chance to
look at the work that was submitted and
I will share my screen a little bit Joan
is going to show us the work but any
high-level feedback first of all like
the overview what's your feeling of the
work you saw this week and I'd love to
share mine but I want to hear yours
first thank you for asking that overall
I think students or what do we call our
our friends their friends friends over
all our friends I want to acknowledge
the hard work that they put into it
there is some experimentation happening
which I want to acknowledge that and
there's some really good design is
happening at the same token I feel like
there's a few things that are still
repeating themselves which I'd like to
bring to your attention and maybe we
could be aware of that as we move
forward we can make the design
even much more successful why do you
think people are repeating the things
that we've been talking about the last
four weeks what's happening here I don't
know can they tell us yeah and maybe
we'll get to that in a second okay no no
ko saing like she's seeing a lot of
experimentation going on
she's also acknowledging this week has
been very difficult because it turns out
the opposite of what you think is true
it's counterintuitive the more options
you have it's a paradox of choice what
do you do when you get caught up in
doing everything under the Sun and we're
seeing a look at that and then we're
wondering like why are you guys
committing the same typographic sins
from previous weeks we don't understand
this is a problem I'm seeing so here's
what I'm saying when I look at this work
let me just look at my screen here I'm
gonna zoom all the way out you guys can
see the layouts that were selected this
week okay and it goes through a pretty
thorough process of looking through
every single work that was submitted and
Marc helps me to curate but then I go
through and even look at what we would
consider the reject pile and I try and
pull some things out of that but what
I'm noticing right away is that I think
we haven't mastered the foundational
design principles yet and we're going
hog-wild and you can see a lot of crazy
stuff happening I'm a little concerned
for some of you I know it's fun to like
throw stuff at the screen and make it
look like a painting but then later on
when you actually have to design a a
website or a new slider you're gonna run
into some serious problems because you
haven't learned the foundational stuff
so if you haven't done so at some point
I would strongly encourage you while the
videos are still up because they may
disappear I don't know weeks 1 2 3 & 4
look at those videos watch take notes
and pay attention ask yourself this
question what did I learn from each of
these episodes write yourself a few
rules and make sure you apply those
because you're gonna be right here all
over again and you're gonna get stuck
and you're not gonna have the benefit of
Milka and I helping you along okay
let's get into it now Anoka is guide
mauka yeah I just want to say what you
said is gold because that's exactly what
happened to me when I was taking
typography class was one of my most
favorite teacher and I took notes notes
notes notes and then the next semester
she disappeared and I
just missed her so much and I needed her
feedback but then when I went back and
looked at my sketches and notes she was
there I had her there so it's spirit
very good very good what you're saying
Chris because take notes friends and
then remember those and Chris is right
those videos may not be there we may
take it for granted take notes so you
can repeat and review revisit I'm sorry
revisit so you can review and implement
the positive notes what you've learned
thank you okay so this week the first
thing I'm looking at is Moe's layout so
most doing a lot of things there he's
putting type on a path he's doing
something with the 8 which I think I
remarked before that was kind of
interesting take on it and we can see
that that element is being used again
right here ok and we see some
transparencies which are going on which
is fine to do all that stuff ok so and
we see like he's doing something funny
with the dates here so it's January
February and then 2018 so taking a step
back after that smus doesn't get here
the area is contrast this I believe
right here is where I would go first
possibly I'll go to this circular thing
and then maybe this big illustration but
then something happens here this little
guy this corner kind of asked me to look
at them because there's lots of contrast
with the round bullets of these use of
these circles and so I think that's
distracting I'm also noticing because I
pulled grids on this earlier I'm gonna
draw a line here for you guys to see
there's some alignment issues going on
so let me select that and get rid of the
arrowheads here good point right so we
we make sure that when we're designing
we don't design in a way where at some
point we have to go back and look at
what we done to make sure it's correct
that it looks correct
so I had this red line here and I'm
gonna bring it up you could see already
there's a long issue term how and
probably this is the step that you guys
need to take not in earlier weeks I
wasn't really zooming in on this because
we had so many bigger global issues you
guys see that right there oh good
oh yeah I know just kind of critique
today okay so I see some problems
already first let me make a layer style
there that's important Chris because
there are these little folks we may be
instilling OCD inside you with all due
respect I apologize for that but you
need OCD if you want to be a good
graphic designer or a designer period
yes now this is not to make light of any
way that is actually clinically
diagnosed with OCD every time we say
that I have to say the disclaimer
because they get upset I'm sorry
now for good miners kind of equate an
obsession with details with actually
clinically diagnosed OCD okay so we we
see this misalignment here and I think
he's pretty on on this one the left edge
is pretty solid
okay that's fine all right so those are
the seven little technical things we
need to just address right away so I
personally always struggle with type on
a circle like this a it's very hard to
read but on top of that he's also done
this inverse thing and look what happens
here when i zoom in you guys see what
happens here he's got the black and
white thing kind of you know it's a
two-faced thing that's going on you know
the Batman character two-faced half of
them is good Harvey Dent and the other
half is a crazy homicidal maniac I don't
love that it's cut because it's rather
arbitrary and it's just inverting things
so I I don't know that's just not a
great creative solution for that that's
just because oh it dips under here it's
hard to read let me just make it black
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
turn on what I did earlier this morning
and I changed a couple of things alright
now I'll walk you through what I changed
and then Milka help me out here okay
so first I instead of just doing znn
which is strange
or maybe that's just the letter n turn
sideways I'm not quite sure what's going
on but why does Z or the end I'm not I'm
not sure at all so the letters I think
that you need are the are the Z the N
and the eight resonate you could
probably drop the e and then I use the
same concept in terms of transparency
and I created this there's still
problems with this but I wanted to show
you
now this is a an illustration made up of
letter forms and I think it looks okay
to me and there's some little problems
so you could see right there it's
because I just kept it all centered on
the same base line I just overlapped
them all and what I did was I bumped
them into the frame so they it didn't
necessarily need to bleed off the frame
for me
and a couple other things I aligned here
you'll see that I change the resonate
back to its normal thing because I'm of
the belief that if you have too many
tricks on the page it's like my mind my
eye doesn't know what to do so I just
reduced it back to its normal thing plus
I also found that this ate with the
lower case re it really reads then ate
and so there's some funkiness going on
the shape is a little odd to that it's
going upwards so I mean let me draw your
attention to what I'm talking about
so if I just draw two lines here though
zoom in so you guys can see it it's a
little bit better it's kind of creating
this odd shape and I like things to flow
a little bit more so I would have
probably moved this away or down and
I'll show you how to do that to create
something that feels asymmetrically
balanced so we could have taken this I
think maybe move itself so that it feels
like there's a nice up-down movement to
it I'm now assuming in and I'm also
seeing other problems here with these
little gaps so I think you have to make
that decision should this be overlapping
or should there be a space and either is
okay where you get into trouble is you
have something in the middle and in the
middle is no person's land it's like you
can't make up your mind okay so some
things to think about right there the
other thing that I had was features
really talks about Saul Bass and Armin
Hofman and I mentioned before in earlier
critiques
when things are far away it implies that
they're not related the family members
right as mochel would say when things
are closer together they said this is a
group we should read these as a group
and they do really should they do really
belong together and they should be read
as a group so that's why I changed it i
reorganize the two columns so that
elicits key ends here yet Sora ends
there so this features and then now it's
grouped together proximity making
bold aligning this all left and changing
the date so it's not gonna jump out and
scream at us
okay Milkha what do you think I really
like what you did nice that was a
brilliant solution to bring that Z and
eight together Wow nice job nice job
I would have loved to see Moe take
advantage of this week's opportunity and
do use different sizes and different
ways and I don't see it yet
I appreciate the maybe you are you are I
should I take that back I apologize
because resin is a different size and
then the journals different size you are
you are but then maybe they're not
singing together yet okay anything else
you want to add
I love the solution you've came up with
but I think as we move forward and we
look at others work we could probably
implement and bring those in here but
for now I really like the solution
you've come up with I'm wondering if we
need with the solution that you came up
with it disappeared my more specific as
to whose solution you came up your
solution Chris's solution yeah I still
want to play with this Leigh I still
love them yes so you are gonna do why
because we've got the Z and the N and
the eight and these are all very
symmetrical shapes and then we're trying
to have the symmetry speak with a
symmetry and that takes a little bit of
more TLC perfect okay
so let's go to the other one okay this
one makes my brain hurt a little bit
we're starting with the tough ones yeah
there's also from oh yeah these are
three from oh here okay so I love the
exploration mo and through this we're
gonna learn something so help me out
here
I did not redesign this one so what do
you think
mocha no I was thinking about this image
and I'm glad Chrissy told me that he did
the other one before because I was
thinking I'm curious to know what else
did this student or this friend to do
worthy some of the other explorations
that they did so we can help them more
because when I look at this one I get
the feeling that there's so much energy
going on with this layout this person is
really open to put his or her foot on
the gas and design with the foot pedal
on the gas so my kudos to you on that
this is really good this means you're
open you're willing to take chances and
you're willing to take experience
experiments so you can learn from it
good for you this is great but now here
we are here we are so what should we do
I'm gonna start designing here cuz I
didn't work on this one okay so you tell
me what you want to do I actually I want
to zoom out so everyone can see this if
we zoom out and squint your eyes what do
we see we see zero one zero two that's
the first thing I see I see resin next I
see journal next I see graphic design so
there's a big party happening everywhere
with a little block at the top right
that is yes that the white space with
the white space where the white space is
saying stop I need to take a breath
you tell Matt this space here yes okay
I know mo you spend a lot of time on
this my kudos to you on that I can feel
a lot of passion for what you did my
kudos for you on that but here's the
thing overall everything is speaking too
loud but I'm curious to know Chris if we
zoom in into only one certain area what
would happen let's zoom in and find an
area that we think something like this
maybe
yeah you see that now you've got new law
r3 it
and but contrast of direction vertical
versus horizontal and you've got this
depth of light and dark coming at you so
and then we can also if you zoom back
please and if you focus on the top right
area yes and then we can zoom into that
area as well
I think actually Chris one more level
and then what we could do is we could
cover everything under from issues and
below it let's put a white box right
please cover issues or just issues
including issue I think I think yes what
do you think Chris I don't know I don't
know where you're going with this so I'm
gonna follow your lead here I'm trying
to see what I can see here okay now oof
beautiful all right now we're getting
there
you see that but now we've got three
those those you see those black boxes on
the left side yeah those black boxes are
not competing with one another you gotta
bring much much much much much closer if
you don't want them to compete with one
another closer and what size scale
blackness or what are we talkin
closeness in terms of proximity okay so
that will be one element that I would
think about folks think of a think of
depth as such is like as if you're
standing in the middle of your kitchen
floor okay and you've got a cup of milk
in your hand and the floor is dark and
then you spill the milk how does that
work what you'll notice that when you
spill the milk you'll have you're gonna
have a focal point there's a big pie and
then splatter away from it so when
you're designing think of the layout in
such a way where there's a good focal
point there's good proximity of darkness
and then
lighter as it goes away and further away
does that help
yeah so I thought about something here
mark thank you for nodding your head I
like that I think Chris is nice to say
yes but if Mark says I got it so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to retype all
this information in here oh wow
no I'm not gonna do that it's got there
I'm done so I always steal the copy
where is it turn off for graphic design
in this issue here we go copy this
there's not that much copy so it's not
really that difficult to do if some
people in Cheddar wondering is it okay
to use the boxes in some cases or you
know that a square box on the top left
the original this box yeah really
technically no I agree
that's next week you guys can we have
week six you could do that not yet week
six we can have line party-line in the
shapes you could do it all kinds of
lines all kinds of weight length depth
that's right and folks when you are
designing such layouts again my kudos to
Moe for going putting his foot on the
gas designing this layout I also want to
add the same token I want to see ones
that are structured because this way
then I can tell where are you going and
how far you need to push yourself pull
or push push yourself or pull yourself
back I'm curious to know if we have any
more Moe's work you do we have layout we
do well show you yeah cool yep so I'm
the what I'm doing right now so I can
explain to everybody that's watching
like what the heck is he doing what I'm
trying to do is take the idea of this
which is to fill the entire page with
height but then to just select one thing
to pull out and I'm gonna show you what
that looks like in one second so I just
want to confirm I have all the copy
which I think I do at this point yeah
you okay so now that I have this box
this is the one time I'm gonna encourage
you use the text boxes because how I lay
this out everything flows in there kind
of nicely right and so I can tighten it
up okay so now you can see that and if I
wanted to I could make it bleed off the
edge now I have some issues here because
the way the graphic design it's broken
up etc it's not looking good but if I
were just to take this and make one
thing like say resonate or the journal
for graphic design or something that I
want to pull out from all of this chaos
I'll do it right now so hit it with the
mold and you can see like this could
still make for a very nice cover so this
is the alternative or event if this is
to this which is type everywhere but
total chaos versus just something that
you can look at and that has room to
breathe and we can push the boundaries
here too if you want I could take this
and literally go like that and just
break it if I wanted to yeah we have to
work through some issues here the way
it's cut off certain problems you know I
wanted to let the type flow pass the
edges I could do that as well and we
need to do a little bit more and now we
can take this and make it even bigger so
it just fills the whole thing now I can
because of the way this file set up I
could reduce or open the lighting and
the tracking lots of things we can do
here but I just wanted to encourage you
guys to keep trying and do different
things but just go back go back remember
week one pick one thing that you want to
pull apart
so here Moe's like I like this I like
ice cream I like hot dogs I like pizza
and all those things are pretty good by
themselves but maybe not all together at
the exact same time okay here's the
third layout demo work on okay I feel so
good cuz now I really believe in you
good job good job
you are really designed with your foot
on the gas because now you realize that
you need to pull yourself back and I'm
seeing three different designs and dad
is a really good thing
why because then that goes to show that
you are capable of designing different
things for different clients and
different projects and if you were to
come at for an interview I would hire
you why because I can I tell to myself
ah mo can work on this project can work
on that other project and I can give him
this client that client instead of well
I'll call you when I have that one
particular project which is all about
you know party posters and I'm here for
that we don't you don't want to
pigeonhole yourself all right this party
posters what's that job about okay this
is nice good job mo Tod you know it I
like the contrast I like how there's a
there's much better flow here killing
this being proved absolutely yes it's
not every single layout you guys no
matter how perfect it is there's always
room for improvement it's it's called
being subjective I thought it's called
refinement sure okay that's in a much oh
okay nice job so okay what are we doing
here now I think what mo was doing here
it was see how he has the are easy and
animate like letting us figure out this
puzzle that he's created he's trying to
complete the seraphs he got rid of which
to me is kind of crazy if you get rid of
something don't replace it what's the
point right so he's replacing the
crossbar of the T which is right here
right he's kind of doing that idea he's
replacing the top and the bottom of the
sea and noka may disagree with me but
it's like you get rid of it just get rid
of it and I think if you just look at
this there's something that's really
beautiful about this this needs to be a
little more refined here and I think
what Chris is saying is that folks you
don't need to spoon-feed your audience
no yeah that's right let some elements
be there to insinuate what it could be
and that's what makes it very
interesting yeah I think the audience
will fill in some of this but we can say
like this is just an illustration at
this point and it's okay for it not to
be fully legible then we can bring the
other elements back in and actually
create a really beautiful layout and it
doesn't take a whole lot like if you
just take one element and you put it in
the right place
maybe not tracked out so much but that's
the idea right you just take something
you have one big idea and then
everything else relax breathe let there
be one star okay you don't wanna you
don't wanna be the drummer he's trying
to step in step on the toes and the lead
singer it just doesn't work that way
okay in that case I would probably bring
the entire a back and just let the Z be
the star okay yeah there you go and you
can play around with this because the R
is cut off you just can't see it the e
is cut off Beatty is so maybe cut off
the end somehow maybe right really cool
things that you can do here mo so I
enjoyed looking at this because I know
that the shapes here are really really
interesting and theirs is gonna be
something that you're gonna do that's
gonna be magical it's gonna sing nice
right so you can start to kind of like
how far do I take it out you know do I
take this side off what side do I need
to take off for it to read right so I'm
gonna try both sides as you can see like
when I design later on I'm going to show
you guys more of my design process that
I try lots of things and there's lots of
ugly things you make on the way until
you start to figure out how to make it
work something crazy here I'm gonna show
you something
this is Milko like this I'm gonna try
something I'm gonna command shift 4 I'm
gonna grab just a chunk of this then I
grab a random chunk let's see if it
works I think there's a lot of potential
in that layout that's what I'm trying to
say there's a lot of potentials in there
yet yeah okay so I did a screenshot
where's my screenshot there it is so I'm
gonna bring my screenshot back in and
show you like if you start to understand
how this stuff works okay you can
actually play around with it and have
some it oops you know like you could
take something and really go to town
like what I'm trying to do here is to
take something has a lot of order which
is this right I take something has a lot
of chaos which is this and I did a
screenshot like as if I print it on the
peak computer made a photocopy of it or
something and then I want to see if
doing something like this can actually
is it little crazy but I just want to
show you guys some techniques that you
can cross you can cut it there's a lot
of different things you can do you could
probably even multiply it on top maybe
make it more transparent but there are
things that you can try so if you take a
little bit of something and that's all
we need just a little bit of it and it
could work out so you can bring in that
flavor that kind of excitement to energy
the density that you were able to bring
before I just drop it in now but I made
this background blacks which I'm going
to do see if I can make this work it's
not working right now not yet but it
just starts with that question like what
if what would I need to do now I want
you to look at that for a second a
little bit of that goes a long way now
if I take this type and I make this type
white maybe that is a little easier to
see maybe now I could reduce this type
down nice love where you going with this
okay if you're gonna have a party have a
real party it was a fake party no it was
this is a professional party hey Chris
question for you so when you were
pasting those other blocks of text and
there is your objective to bring some
order to the chaos this block yeah and
when you were doing it before also wait
that's the question one more time yeah
when you were pasting those blocks of
text when you had you know the three
patterns side-by-side and just generally
speak are you trying to
create some order there with the chaos
okay first yes let me let me answer that
question okay when I screen captured
this it was really inspired because
Milko says you know if you zoom you
close enough some of its interesting it
could work right but when you see it all
like this it's just too much so if I
really was even bolder I would just go
in and grab a fragment of this and I'm
gonna do it again so let me do it
oops sorry something works why not try
it again right go back this is exactly
what I mean by potentiality I'll take a
random chunk here I should be a little
bit more careful about how I cut these
and if you were doing it like be more
intentional right now we're kind of
designing on the fly oh good we're gonna
make a lot of bad layouts on the way of
hopefully making a better layout but
it's no guarantees on any of this stuff
happening
okay now I drop that in there look I did
shoot sorry my computer while Chris is
doing that may I add something to that
question is that I think what Chris is
doing here is he's playing with Kay at
least playing with contrasts of chaos
versus structure remember we talked
about their different contrasts when
you're using elements of design and
you're applying it to principle of
design one of the principle of design is
contrast so right now Chris is playing
with contrast of space as well as
structure and structure is organized
versus chaos it could be mechanical
versus hand-drawn yes
okay so when we take a piece of this
it's pretty good when we take all of it
it's overwhelming so when I brought in
an image I was like it still is very
chaotic so I realized then that only a
little bit if it's going to work now
what's really cool about this is the
first thing I did Mark to answer your
question is I thought maybe by repeating
it you to give me a little bit of
structure but it's just so heavy that
it's just it's overwhelming to me
maybe if I cut this up differ
maybe if I hid them in letterforms which
I can do I'm going to show you guys in a
second okay so the I want to show you
guys possibilities of things that you
haven't thought about yet maybe and/or
we're afraid to try cuz you didn't know
how I'm going to show you so look at
this little sliver here not by itself is
pretty cool because I can imagine like
if you were working on a brand identity
system for some company you made some
tape packaging tape and you printed out
the core values of the company and you
did this kind of crazy all different
typefaces orientation bold that could
look really cool so if this were
repeating tape it looks something like
that
so little doses of it you can handle it
you could manage it okay now it needs
the rest of the copy of course and it's
not relating to anything and we'll
figure that out maybe in a little bit
forget we can probably take maybe this
guy out all right and then put it back
in okay you can talk about ideas or
principles thinking right now is that
when we go to the experimental I'm
really glad what you're showing to
everyone because when we go to
experimenter everything's there's going
to be a lot of hodgepodge a lot of
craziness but what Chris is showing you
is a high you can bring that
experimental to where you have learned
the basics of how to organize and
structure your hierarchy of typography
so your high crop typography
can be very clean very organized but
then boom you can bring that little nice
bit of an experimental in there to pump
it up and make it interesting and make
it enticing okay that's one way to do is
I'm gonna need to spend a lot of time to
make this one work right but then this
is really ordered right whereas this is
really chaotic and now I realize I
probably want a longer strip of this but
whatever that's one way to make this
layout work so it's getting a little bit
of that flavor that mo put in there
which I like and if he didn't do that we
would have anything to talk about but
when I was doing before when you guys
weren't looking was I just took part of
that I cropped it where like you could
find some really beautiful things in
there that means that the assets ideas
were good it's just
this is what the artist and the designer
does it's just is it like that one
element that one corner that texture is
where I want my focus to be I can see a
series of posters like this or book
covers that have just typography cut up
like this where I can't read it and then
everything else is really small really
elegant and there's lots of rooms
breathe now this was dropped in you're
kind of randomly literally randomly but
you can find other things nice you can
find other croppings and I remember an
assignment it's in lettering where all
we would do is draw a couple other forms
really big and drop them in yeah
cropping is very powerful they're very
powerful in fact that was something I
wanted to also mention about cropping is
that folks you're not prison to this
dimension what is the dimension again
what is it this ain't half by what was
the dimension I don't know what it is
okay so you're not you know whenever
black forces when I'm designing let's
say like the format is like a knife a
lemon let's just say that that way I
don't start with a page and a half by 11
I start with a page 17 inch by 17 inches
I come in there I start putting put my
layout down I find a focal point I find
where my satellite goes and then I come
in and boom I crop it where is where do
I need to go try that and you'll be
impressed of how much more variety of
different design comes across your your
decisions yes I'm it's like five point
three by eight inches okay cool yeah now
I'm gonna change my units back the cool
thing about working in vectors like
there's really no such thing as page
size you can really scale up to whatever
degree you want okay so I'm gonna leave
this one well excuse me some good ideas
here I think this would be actually more
interesting if this were brought in so
that it wasn't all there so that where
I'm looking for the asymmetrical beauty
here and if you wanted to you could crop
that off as well you don't have to
because it's already cropped off at the
top but finding this good spot for that
maybe your work on it some more okay and
I'm noticing that mo is saying that he's
making a tribute to Neon Genesis you
folks if you're ever having inspirations
from anyone maybe you can drop that in
there you know maybe can you let us know
this was my inspiration so we can help
you and talk about where the inspiration
comes from an based on and and in
relation to what you've done
yes you can directly email Milka okay
I'll be honest you guys I don't really
care about you inspiration look good I
don't care what your inspiration is it's
cool to draw from things like street
signs or gutter
you know or packaging that you people
don't look at and put it in there but
you got to find a way to make it work
yes that's the secret yes because that's
what I meant to help them yeah yeah so
what Milko would do is they've she had
the time in patience what she would do
is go in there and look at it and adjust
it and kind of work on it with you to
see like oh you like that part of it
okay I mean let me bring that part back
and make it work for you but me yeah
yeah okay let's look at another layout
here's one this one was sent in from
Cole Fraser very nice layout very simple
just minor things that are bugging me
okay I see that you're you're applying a
lot of the principles that we talked
about in previous weeks which is you
take the 8 and then cut it off and put
it back on the top what bothers me about
this is is that resonate reads
horizontal like this way and then you
rotate the 8 which makes it feel like
it's a separate element usually when you
break the orientation you're saying what
kind of related but we're not the same
thing and that's problematic for me so I
what I want to do is to take this I want
to rotate it back so that I can read it
right like if that were on the same base
line I don't know why I can't find that
base line Chris may I disagree on you
yeah of course you can I don't mind it I
hear you absolutely the reason I don't -
because they they're all treated
in the same way in terms of same weight
and same size and then because these are
about artists and graphic designers I
think it's okay to push that edge a
little bit more and make it a little bit
crazier if there's so much simplicity
happening in this page that that
craziness that awkwardness for me is
acceptable for me okay beautiful see so
this is the subjectivity of design that
we can have different opinions and I
respect my logo so much she's probably
much better topographer than me so I'm
still gonna stand by my opinion though
and it's an opinion so you guys this is
where you guys get to choose who you
want to listen to and how you want to
follow and you can make it work in the
hands of a good designer you can make
anything work I'm also bothered by this
to be honest because it's like now when
I read as oh okay or is this comes a
couple things but it's beautiful layout
really good structure here and I think
you're like 85 90 percent of the way so
it was really difficult for me to work
on top of this now I will show you what
I did okay and I change it a little bit
okay so I got rid of that so I can read
it
Wow and then oriented the eight the
right reading and then I just group
things a little differently and I'm just
trying to repeat and pull elements
together and that's it not much of a
difference here I wanted to bring the
baseline of the II back in towards the
resonate to let people know that it's
still related it's just bumped out it's
a little baseline shift so there you
have it I think you started off with a
really good layout well it's kind of
hard for me to do anything so I'm not
even sure that's much better any better
but I just wanted to show you some
options there
I would may I make a suggestion please
if we go back to what Cole has I really
like what you did Chris beautiful what a
beautiful interpretation but if you go
back to what Chris has if I were to just
take that layout and push it a little
bit better make it better just attack is
I would take the Journal of graphic
design and I would see what would happen
if I move it a little bit more hold the
shift key down and move it towards the
left a little bit more thank you
it opens up this space a little bit more
that's it that's it yeah yeah all right
so that's coal hi this oh no it's so
nice sorry I don't know why I talk all
day and it's fine I get on air and I
can't talk anymore my voice is gone all
right let's see what other layouts do we
have to look at here I'll try to help
you out here
can we talk about that one please by
Joseph I just saw something
let's stay right there you see how the
word res and in an 8 they're all the
same size but they are playing as
islands friends what if we do bring them
next to each other in a you know you
know you know in a different alignment
it so I like the fact that you broke it
up Joseph but I'm curious to know you
see how there's a lot of scattered space
between them I want to give you the
kudos of using different sizes in
different way good job I think there's a
beautiful depth happening here but then
when we zoom back they are easy and 1/8
they're fighting with each other and
that is bothering me what should we do I
would like to play with the re Z and the
n8 and then just just bring them closer
to each other so you don't have those
straighter open and some of the fonts
tell me what you want me to do and I'll
be happy to move it for you all right
let's move the letter 8 above top left
to the R and I'm so intuitive I have to
put my hand in there and see how it
speaks to me yeah ok good problem solved
ok nice but let's zoom back out again a
little bit let's see the difference now
you see how there's more of a focal
point do you guys see that but just
moving that 8 does I help everyone ok
Chris continue please no what else
should we do I'm listening yeah I like
to see maybe I like the relationship of
the eight and the resin and now I do I
do but now we have a bit of a dead space
on the left as a margin how can we fix
that maybe we can bring something maybe
just a word in this issue just in this
issue bring that out hmm
beautiful look at that the page goes in
and out the whole entire space is now
active why ask yourself why why well
here's the thing first of all we've got
the focal point on the the eight are
easy okay let's take resume out again
what happens my eye goes out with the
are easy and then my eye comes back in
within this issue and then I read down
with the name of the artist and it goes
out and then it comes back in from the
eight and I read are easy again and then
back same format again does that help
yeah I think so I'm just asking for our
audience as you throw the sound effects
in there I have to like why why I tell
us why okay there are a couple of other
issues let's bothering me you see the
side face here it's already light to
begin with and then you make even
lighter and you can see even it kind of
at this size it's in a scale it's very
very hard to read I've cautioned you
guys about doing this you don't need to
do this why we do this every single week
I have no idea just make it black you
really don't need to do that Joseph okay
nice job just make sure you can read it
and at certain point sizes you got to
just make sure that it's legible then
that the data Snead's to be legible okay
let's move on let's go somewhere else
where should we go - oh I should have
shown you that actually could we talk
about the next to the Joseph I'm sorry I
don't mean to interrupt you
but I'd something which one to go use
the one on the right the black buy yeah
but you but you Raj
okay the right beautiful layout but I
just don't understand I'm sorry there
are just forgive me for giving you tough
love we've talked about this multiple
times what's up with those lines that is
blocking the entire layout why what do
you mean what lines I'm talking about
I'm talking about graphic design Journal
of graphic and then the day Jan February
2000 why do we have those why they're
blocking the space you don't want to see
here's the thing you won this space to
flow and if you have something there
boom it can't flow it's dead end and
that's what they're doing nice job Chris
there you go that's how you make this
space open up and flow I would also take
those two bars on the sides where it
says graphic design and the Journal of
graphic yeah yeah they don't belong that
no no no you can't have them vertical it
could be in the same direction as
everything else oh well actually it does
work in the spine yeah yep
so I'm trying to find a spot for it so
then just in the spine closer to
somewhere in that vicinity yeah and then
the other thing is that folks please pay
attention this is almost in half if I
were to take this piece of paper and
fold it in half diagonally it's almost
in the middle be aware of that if you
want your layout to be dynamic you gotta
make it asymmetrical not symmetrical and
if it's almost symmetrical almost the
same size what happened it gets flat now
remember that when you're designing we
don't want to see that they were no we
don't want to see that okay so the
problem is a lot of times you guys are
doing this and everybody loves the
diagonal layouts and it just really just
made
I can work first you guys so sometimes
you can maybe fine because it really
limits where you could move things I
just mess this out but okay all right
mocha is there anything else you want to
say about this good that beautiful
beautiful job and that what you need is
that it's so fantastic Chris fantastic
now what you need is a little bit of a
satellite at the bottom where a bottom
right so this way the eye travels around
and it's not a dead space at the bottom
what do you want to put here
I wouldn't know no no no no no no that
doesn't speak to the direction so let's
have it in the same direction please as
the same angle or it could be actually
rotated 90 degrees yes and then maybe
bring it
ooh beautiful anywhere in that vicinity
maybe a little bit yes you're in the
right track okay so you want to move it
closer to the bottom yeah
closer to the bottom no no not the whole
thing just that january/february thingy
right now we're creating in the L shape
so I would probably move it like maybe
half an inch to the left okay yeah yeah
some yeah fantastic fantastic and
friends this is where you get to refine
things that you don't know till you try
that okay this is not the hundred
percent solution but it is definitely in
the right direction and we can compare
and contrast contrast the two next to
each other and see how the one on the
left with those lines with those line of
typography is kind of boxing it whereas
the one on the right has the room to
breathe so what milk is talking about
right now
is this okay she's seeing this box
that's being created let me make this a
little bit thicker so you guys can see
it let me scale it up a little bit
exactly exactly I do the same thing
online get in there
Jesus because that's what she's feeling
yeah hope you guys can see that yeah so
we're gonna break it up a little bit
Chrissy family eyes you know for next
week when you're doing box when you're
doing lines I think in this case it
might work in my work to have a line
like that for next week when you're
using lines because what it does it that
line that box is creating a page layer
and the fact that the resonate is
sticking out it looks like there's more
going on outside that page so it's like
a page within the page so by putting
that box it works but but because we
didn't have that box and these lines
were coming in from one to three space
it wasn't working it was too weak okay
something was bothering me about this
layout and no cuz you're right it's like
we're not gonna be able to solve the
layout within two minutes of art
direction and moving things around but I
find this to be too heavy on the top for
me personally so what I'd like to do
switch these to January February so I'm
gonna take this thing I'll move down
here I'm gonna rotate it I'd like to see
if it would work better here I'm not
sure if it will I'm a try I don't take
this and rotate it I should leave it
where it was I think I was here right or
did I that's a no it was the other way
[Music]
okay so that I don't know if that works
any better maybe this is too big I like
it you just have the magic touch Chris
folks again hi Chris maybe maybe I don't
know it you still need some more work is
that okay no I'm trying to like
rebalance it a little bit
I I like it again I would I what I
really really recommend my students is
to do these multiple designs next to
each other and then you look you compare
and contrast and that's how you learn
and that's you allow the work to speak
back to you and that's how you learn
what's working what's not working ok
that's what you're doing Chris you the
book is not speaking to you yet that's
not it's not speaking to me it's not
saying hello how you doing where's my
type I want to go back to maybe making
this bold yes a little kind of knot a
little spice it up or a little or we
anchor with some meaty resonate at the
bottom and it's it still needs a more
work but ok so we have something there
ok love it now what that touch was just
perfect
well thank you I try and tell my wife
that all the time oh you know what
there's so many crazy layouts submitted
this week I like that crazy one actually
yeah yeah which was crazy scrolled it
was at the top
yes that one to the left yes yes this
one I love these ones I love it I love
it again but it's missing a little bit
of satellite otherwise it's I I think
this is this is a fantastic layout in
terms of being crazy and broken up in
fact these sort of layouts they do
really really well if you cut them up
and we paste them down with hand because
then they're not that's they're not as
perfect a little bit crooked and you
know yes yes keep edgy and edgy yes a
little bit crooked and edgy Ryan I'm
curious to know what were you thinking
is Ryan here I think he's in here nope
no cuz really on top of this
nice job see how the the pieces are
talking to one another I
love how the journal for graphic design
is pushing the Z down there that's what
I'm talking about there's a dynamic
happening between these little forms and
he's using to wait bold with resin and
then light with eight and then he's
using at different sizes with the other
information folks I want to encourage
you to go further with different sizes
and different weight and what I mean by
that is is to create depth how do you
create depth I'm trying to go that depth
with different sizes and different
weight all right
I'm pushing Paul jump and squat okay a
couple of problems for me personally I
like I like this kind of layout and I
was thinking man if you want to make
something crazy go all the freakin way
just go bananas go crazy type on us
right so have some problems mocha I
don't like that the baselines are all
weird I don't know I think it needs to
be more weird or more aligned so that's
why you did by hand cuz when you do it
by hand then it's not so structured and
doesn't need to be that clean yeah it
creates more there's more spice to it
okay so you don't technically literally
have to do it by hand but you have to
understand the principles that Noah's
talking about so if I took this and I
command chef oh I'll outline the type
and now pretty much I'm doing it by hand
you know and I can ungroup this right
which I just did and I can move this I
can move it not gonna rotate it a little
bit so it's like it's got some flaws to
it mm-hmm so it's not it's never gonna
be totally perfect and some things might
run into each other okay
and maybe that looks bad I don't know
but that's what she's talking about so
that there's a little bit more kind of
chaos and haphazard randomness and
beauty in the random the wabi-sabi if
you will okay so yeah you're open to the
cern dippity of when the text is laying
there that oh I didn't intended it but
it looks better than I thought better
than I was expecting to do it myself
yes and you might even catch fragments
for example you
if I took the pen tool and I drew
something like that yes and I'm good D
for default hex to swap that and make it
like that and if I had some of this oops
blocking something else as I'm cutting
and pasting things in you ought to
appreciate that kind of randomness that
nOCA is just reference right now right
nice thing to open up it's like huh what
does that look like gorgeous perfect
another poster that I would put my money
down and buy it now in that spirit I'm
like oh let's try some things here this
is what I wound up doing I'm not saying
it's better just it's totally crazy
oh so the first thing I did was I just
made sure that this baseline shift was
was the same so this one is where's wait
did you just do this I just did it this
morning yeah oh wow look at you you're
so brilliant I took this I know okay I
looked at the 8 and the 8 is minus 16 in
terms of 16 points below the baseline
and so I did do that with a Z and they
hate and then I started really playing
around like I want to take the same idea
that you have here which is that this is
just jutting out of the empty space I
thought what if it really pushed things
apart like in the old days of metal and
wood type you couldn't really get the
lighting and all that stuff to overlap
so if a piece of metal would type
existed here it would push the letters
out and you can't get any closer than
that because it's surrounded by material
so I started looking at that I also
thought about this idea that in
sometimes when you're doing letterpress
and you're printing that you run sheets
through and they they rotate they miss a
line and you're doing practice sheets
and you might get this kind of stamping
effect it's going on here so I just
started going in and this is one of the
last things that worked on is to break
up the letter spacing and angles and
just like there's just cool explosion
it's very expressive and I just wanted
to push it out and see what happens even
doing things like this where yeah
there's some weird stuff going on there
for sure a little refinement there could
make that work but just to show you like
where you can go with this kind of stuff
that's it and folks you might
ask yourself well I can't sell this to
my client again it depends with your
client is if you're dealing with
conservative clients there's no way you
can well I don't know it all depends you
have to know who your client is you have
to know forces if this is for sci-arc
Southern California architecture school
whoo this would be rocking if this was
if Frank Gehry was your client whoo this
would be rocking you have to know who
your client is so you can push and pull
also when you do such work on your own
you feel more confident and you know and
you're you are also lit you are
developing your visual literacy you're
taking yourself to the Graduate School
you're not stopping by the first or
second or third grade because you have
to understand that the client in general
our client what's their visual literacy
their visual literacy is probably up to
third grade I don't know I'm just making
that up you know you know what I mean
it's to a certain point whereas we want
to teach you so many other things that
you can come in here and bring that a
little bit higher because you're so way
up here you know how to massage this and
make this better I hope that makes sense
it's how it makes sense it's it's about
the way of seeing and when you open up
the way you see you're opening yourself
up to serendipity and serendipity is
happy accident serendipity is you as
another best friend of yours you can
also I can see this working for a flier
for a theater group or performance art
or some jazz festival of improvisation
something like that a comedy club
there's not some more applications that
is than you think yeah yeah it's got
action in there it's got it's got a lot
of Dynamis on in there but you got to
make sure you do this for something
that's appropriate this is like tea time
for a bunch of old ladies maybe not
excuse me
[Laughter]
but you know what you're talking about
like let's say hypothetically speaking
maybe this is not a good layout for a
client that is about finance unless
unless it's like now for in in these
chaotic times you need a calm place and
then you have a really simple logo watch
this guy's
what's the financial institution that
you guys know like where you would
invest money let me say something like
so Chase Bank Oh chase bank that's too
easy mark mm-hmm like a hedge fund
management kind of like where Vanguard
and okay and guard mark we know you're
very good with money wish I had some
it's got a boat you gotta make it dude
are you giving him financial advisor I
know Milka you know I just show on
topography and take financial place for
you if you don't heed that warning you
know whatever are you going what
beautiful contrast logo and you put it
somewhere it let know this once I
introduced that element like I told you
like once you introduce a new element
things change right so if you had
something that was a very simple really
conservative I wanted to find like a
monogram something very classical a
crown
ing maybe oh yeah ing that's all that's
all right and you'll see what what can
happen the Vanguard one's hurting me a
little bit visually okay it's because
you're separating them you can't
separate them you gotta have them be all
on one planet they can't be Mars and
Earth or Jupiter sorry guys won't let me
save this that girl mm-hmm but I can do
this I can save the image to downloads
and Chris while you're doing this I just
want to give you give kudos to you for
this brilliant idea because
we are going through these on certain
times where things are crumbling and yes
you're right Vanguard can come in here
and help you what a brilliant
advertisement I concept here thank you
to whoever did this whoever designed
this and folks here's another thing I
want to say while Chris is doing this is
that none of us have the answer it's
together when we work we come up with an
answer and and again I would have never
come up with this idea or maybe Chris
with all the respect you might not know
either but now we're inspired because
you're untouchable in my mind also
invincible Wow I love this I love this I
might want to see a little bit more of a
digging coming and I don't like that
space in there that that block of
triangle space I like to see something
dripping in there uh-huh
exactly where your cursor is
and folks hope this is I hope this is
broadening your horizon in terms of how
you can take something that is not in
the norm and it's outside the norm and
you can bring it and use it in the norm
and that's what we want you to think we
want you to think outside the box as
much as possible by doing all these
different trials one of the reasons why
I got my first job in advertising was
because of I think my typography skills
being able to take a headline and making
it kind of say or show perform the
meaning of the word itself and if you
have just a little like legal copy here
and then this was like has some kind of
a really simple headline you might be
able to submit this to the client and
say hey are we open to exploring things
like this and if you have a very
progressive client or an art director
creative director boss it might let you
try something like that so you can make
this work guys because the contrast of
the chaos and the energy of this is
grounded by this if we integrated some
of the colors so maybe a little
something up here it would tie the whole
layout together but that's our
exploration into good job good job for
flexing your design muscles nice I love
it keep on keep doing it again folks
we're not asking you to do crazy designs
all the time we want you to do the whole
range of design anything from
conservative all the way to craziness
okay explore because if you don't you
never know okay
next layout Jason Jacob Titus I like it
I like it I like it I like it and he's
using lines I like it I thought this was
a nice one sweet job sweet job if I were
to Finnick it a little bit the space at
the bottom maybe needs to match yourself
with the space at the table or bring the
entire resonate just down a little bit
and then I would probably go in there
let me see you get closer to look at it
a problem fix some of the sort of the
tracking what do you do it and I would
probably in terms of an overall picture
it looks really good in terms of details
I would go in there and clean it up
refine it such as why is Saul Bass and
the name of the artist going upward
mobility and then in this issue graphic
disclosure is going downward mobility I
would probably fix those okay you want
to orient them the same way yes please
up or down you know me I like upward
mobility don't we are yes are we talking
about uh-huh and then what if we bring
the word in this issue and then align it
at the with the bottom area where
graphic this claw how does that work is
that is that too much of a staircase
looking or what what do you think Chris
I don't know just layout has some
problems for me so I'm gonna do the old
box trick again I take this and I take
this and I take this that's not exactly
a beautiful layout and so this one needs
some work in my opinion I think there's
some really good components here and so
I also then took the liberty to try and
design something again working with the
original design intent it's kind of
tough sometimes and so here's what I did
okay first I wanted to make sure I did
not break the rule of not using rules
and so I was playing around with the
resonate and it's playful so instead of
creating it the vertical line which you
have here I just used the stroke the
vertical stroke of the end to create
that same idea or illusion and so I
brought it down my instincts were
similar to Milkha's which is to take it
and bring it down further away and then
I started to work with everything else
now here I'm doing the type the opposite
direction going down I also didn't love
the open tracking sometimes that works
and sometimes
doesn't I wanted to create more
alignment here off this very strong
vertical this nicely well and I was
almost done with this and then I was
like what do I do with a space here it
didn't really solve this the same
problem right so I was thinking we need
other mark a gesture something in this
corner to kind of really activate the
space so I just put in a plus symbol and
then that created a new problem which is
what do I do with that alignment and so
I was like let me try that
so just took in this issue and just
broke apart like that and that's as far
as I got there are some other weird
things going on down here
guys if we're looking to refine your
this okay
so if you submit three layouts to us
Jason do your best like really dial in
the details once you have the initial
expression and because it's gonna make a
difference no got your thoughts I like
what you did beautiful job
I also understand what Jason is doing is
probably having that you know keeping it
simple having an horizontal vertical in
terms of layout he is following the laws
of third and he does have that satellite
where it brings your eye back in it's
simple and clean it's like it's like
rotating vertically and then
horizontally but as yours become Wow
that mercedes-benz that I wish to have
which class of Mercedes I want to send
more Roy's maybe may mock Lamborghini
okay all right
and and in case you guys are wondering
why did I put this symbol in there
besides to fill up the space the reason
why is this I'm gonna show you okay if
you take this and you rotate it there's
repetition of form okay actually that
doesn't look bad there either nice so
you see they're signed that this cross
is X right so I just wanted to take that
subliminally link it to this autumn area
and though that was all just take this
idea and repeat it but then provide some
variation so as you guys known in
typography it's very similar to music
theory which is
consonance things that are same or
repetition and then dissonance
consonance and dissonance so things that
are familiar certain kind of harmonies
or beats or chords and then repeating
that but changing a pitch or something
like that and that's all I'm doing here
so if you're really good at music and
you understand music theory you can
probably map it to typography as well
very similar principles there if you
take something like this layout where is
it this one it's just a lot of stuff and
it feels noisy and our mind is because
there it's discordant but if you take
that and you apply it here that's like
the little record being scratched or
something but there's still a strong
beat a good vocal that's laid on top
some chords and then it's just something
unexpected there and that's that's kind
of like finding that balance folks just
so you know that what Chris and I are
suggesting these are suggestions they're
not the answers there's multiple
multiple answers to these solutions but
what we're suggesting you is directions
of where you can make your elements even
more successful okay so look I think at
this time we should look at the markups
that you've done
oh no you already covered them every
weasel how did that happen that is BS I
cannot be yes right I assure you you
already covered because good from the
top to bottom I want okay so I'm gonna
stop the share okay okay yes now you can
share okay are we getting tired here
scream I just want to see how you mark
things up even you know just quickly
show people like there's a lot of
different ways to critique work if you
and I were in a classical I would not be
jump on an illustrator like this I would
just yeah top of your thing so now we're
looking at what you're doing yeah what
I'm doing I mean InDesign
right so I we talked about this you know
I was going to talk about it we talked
about this and you wanted to talk about
this yeah so let's talk about it let's
talk about it hopefully all right let's
here's here's my trick I usually step
back
and look and what's the first thing I
see I see these lines and these semi
circles and then this area and then this
and there so one two three four and then
this space mmm
because the gravity is pulling down on
it it fells like this space is being
crushed and we have talked about how
space is your best friend we have talked
about it right so let's see how we can
figure this out Chris you're really good
at your map putting your magic touch
into this is a PDF in front of me so I
can't really change our limits around
but I wanted to bring this to friends
attention yes so what's your question if
you want it to otherwise Adams I I can
talk about what I want to do or what the
problem mark it up okay what I want to
do is I don't use InDesign so InDesign
once I use it long enough then I can get
back into it I don't use it very often
so I can't really yeah now I get to
email cats like hold down shift and sure
Chris anything for you so we talked
about this how this is speaking first
yeah let me use my increase my point
size okay we talked that that's first
second and then third and fourth okay
yeah so we're having some islands this
layout is not working I like how the e
and the Z is trying to do something but
this is competing with this okay there's
too much competition this one's saying
me me me me me me and I'm bringing this
to your attention so you're aware of it
and not to do these things and chris has
said this multiple times is one trick at
a time try one trick let me just move
quickly as we're going through these and
then maybe if you want to stop me and I
refine them that
be great ok sweet job with this one this
is another design that where I feel like
oops I went to close look at another
design that when we zoom in how gorgeous
is that so gorgeous this is the the
spilled milk I'm talking about we've got
the big spill and then the little and
you know as it has it spread itself out
and there are unifications so I feel
like there's a lot of collaboration
happening between the elements and
that's a good thing I like how the 8 is
turned upside down but he's repeating it
and then we come over here be aware of
the piano effect France piano what do I
mean it's dark light dark light you
won't you don't want to have dark I what
you wanted is you want to have dark and
then radiate it into light and you might
want to bring like a little bit of a
blurp in there to create more depth with
full so star zoom back how the elements
are working this is fine could it be
improved yes it can be improved and I
really need to get my hands in there to
refine it to make it make it better I
will move to we've talked about this you
see how the 8 is is sticking itself out
then we're creating a dead space here
dead space dead space let's see this is
a cool one Chris we can come back and
talk about this one ok yeah this is a
really cool one I again I love how there
are these little little refinements that
are happening sorry about that
I like how there are these little
refinement a lot of time has been spent
on this look at this just this area
right here this area right here is
gorgeous so if I were to draw a box
around it didn't do it if I were to draw
a box beautiful page layout very nice
you know my eyes going out it's coming
back in it's going out that there's a
lot of random there's a lot of things
that are happening you're following the
law of third here so very nice very nice
and then again we can come back and talk
about how we can refine this because
there's some this needs to be cleaned up
maybe the tracking and the letting could
be a little bit tighter maybe this could
be pushed up a little bit it needs it
needs more tight they need something we
need to tighten things up here I want to
see more depth with different sizes and
different weights we're being a little
bit
forgive me with all the respect stingy
using them ok another edgy one very nice
let's use my this there's an edgy one I
like what you whoever has worked on this
has done this is really really edgy
really cool keep it up and then you're
balancing it with something that is more
organized and we talked about this chaos
versus more organized so that's nice
here
dead space right right away we see that
dead space please be aware of that
ok be aware of dead space this is a nice
little trick 1 2 - okay that's the date
January February 20,000 18 alright cool
that's cool at first I didn't get it but
then when I got it the second time
and then I went ah that's smart so
that's a cool thing to have Chris please
stop me if you want to in no no your
great job keep going okay this is good
this is fine fine I would probably
tighten the tracking more and this one
what do you guys think
tell me please somebody's chat me what
do we see what do we not see here we see
the dead space a but like good job good
job good job good job good job we need
to push it up a little bit more so it's
not dead so it becomes an active space
be careful of these two that right now
they're competing with one another
because graphic discourse open and close
they're talking to one another there I'm
sorry fighting with one another again
what we want to do is we want to make
sure that there's a hierarchy first read
secondary and third read and how do we
do that is by zooming out and then we
can look and see so we see this verse
and then these two are kind of playing
with each other maybe we could reduce
the size of that one
alright let's see where else
maybe one or two more and then okay
let's see one or two more mm-hmm I think
we've talked about all of them in
general let's talk about you knows a
unit Yoon ji Yoon ji good job good job
good job very nice this is what I'm
talking about using different size in
different way
she's definitely creating depth because
we see graphic design first and then
january/february
very nice job of hierarchy and then the
rest of the information at the bottom
but what I'm wondering I'm wondering is
a bad the entire let me show you the
entire margin that we have here and then
we go to into something like maybe 500 I
know this is crazy
he's too much but let's see what happens
and do it I'm gonna sit now to watch so
I read that 40 okay you see all that
margin do we want that I don't know I'm
asking you that question because that my
eye does my eyes do go there this would
be a very very good example where you
can take the page and road it rotate it
tilt it and move it around this is one
of those exercises where you can come in
here and say what would happen if I drop
my page like this or what would happen
if I take my page and and and maybe you
rotate it let's see
you design it and then you come out here
and then you decide how much you want to
crop it okay nice good job I'm gonna try
that mark Chris you know you got some
talent there my friend good yeah I think
I did great thanks remember we're
cutting the umbilical cord it's not
about you and me it's about the work
good job good job
so when you have a good design you can
have the liberty to change the
orientation and the cropping of it and
it will actually look really good so I
gotta go back to sharing my desktop I
think on my screen I hope this was
helpful folks
yeah most definitely so where's my
illustrator I think it's this one here
all right we're back so I was just
playing around with a layout mm-hmm Yugi
you did a great job really nice laughs
there's not really a lot that I want to
do to it so I didn't know what else to
do to be honest but I was just trying to
break up the information differently I'm
I'm not done with this is not resolved
but I noticed that not very many people
are breaking up information in tiny
blocks like this and and to encourage
you I think Alicia did please do back
count
Alicia Alicia did so she took the
blocking of the block and broke it up
and so I think that's really nice and
that's what I think drew me to this I
think there's still some unresolved
issues for me and I just think it's like
a lot of different things happening but
they're not all coming together just yet
and I think changing the orientation of
this Alicia it just might help you a
little bit I don't know maybe so that
these things start to come together and
then we still have a lot of work to do
in terms of making the layout all work
with each other I think Milko wanted you
to push this up north a little bit not
sure that yet so we can keep working on
this Alicia I think overall it's a very
nice layout very
if you were to push it as Chris and I
were trying to encourage you yes you can
but overall it's a it's got the it's got
the good element it's got the good
rhythm and the eyes flowing around so
beautiful job so I want to connect this
you know that's that's really what I'm
trying to do so there's this Raz with a
M - and then the underscore so I'm
trying to repeat elements and to
continue the orientation maybe so that
it it feels like it's part of the same
same gosh I
my wife says don't do this but I'm gonna
do it anyways I just couldn live
dangerously is to tell you guys avoid
using Boyd using these text box when
when it's not a paragraph it makes your
design much more difficult to work with
okay and you'll see that all the time
you just want to grab it and pull it and
push it okay all right this this light
you already talked about Joshua Gilley I
did work on this a little bit I think
it's a beautiful land it's really um I
can tell it Josh knows how to like add
things where they need to be and he's
kind of painting with type I'm curious
if he could do this without adding all
this extra information he even wrote his
online the journal not just any journal
if there's a lot of stuff going on here
but he knows he needs a little dab here
a little - airline uncle we put a big
box just temporarily on top of the
entire name of the artist just just to
see what the layout would look like okay
I could do that
I'm curious thank you Chris yeah a white
maybe no no give me a second I'm sorry
whip it out Chris you're so fast you're
so good why she's working you faster ah
look at that
ah look at that layout all right friends
what do you say what do you have to say
talking about minimalism ah this is
another poster I would pay I would pay
for me money here yes
listen you guys you can you don't need
to have to have a client to make money
and you can make your own stuff and sell
them that's called being an artist
that's the difference being in a fine
artist and a designer the designer has a
client who tells you what to do or they
have an intention where you're trying to
help themselves the problem but as an
artist you come up with the solution you
come up with the problem and you resolve
it Chris do we have a lecture on how to
be a sustainable artist that's a whole
course but we didn't talk about that
later I thought that there's ones and
the twos here with this is complicated
and I realize I don't have hepatica
black and so this is obviously not how
bad it cuts got some weird curves and so
I just wanted to go in and update that
right there so that is now Helvetica and
it's bol this should be good enough I
mean if you really want to go that bold
you can I just want to get rid of some
of this stuff now one way around this
and you're gonna find out next week
because you get to use lines and shapes
is you're like okay I don't want to
repeat all this res res res like what's
the point of all that you can do the
same thing by drawing a line yeah oh
sure
so you take this line if Milko doesn't
jump on me before I'm able to yeah then
you did that see this right here quite
the same what that could create the same
idea you can take this and you can
literally rotate that line nine degrees
and you can create this nice trick you
know you're gonna be able to do the
exact same thing so this is what what
Joshua already realizes in his thing
he's like I'm missing something I want
more here and the way he's done that is
he just created more through typography
but next week it all opens up you see
that same idea same feeling once you
know what to do with it you can add
these kind of elements and I won't tell
you I won't spoil the the ending of the
movie but you you need to learn how to
use these things to communicate and not
just be purely decorative and we'll show
you that and Chris you're alluding to
one of the very important principles of
design and that's rhythm movement
repetition yes
all right so a couple more layouts here
we were to talk about that when you zoom
in your Bertram Bertram you gotta get
the details right man this little sucker
bothers me to no end here so let's let's
let's just fix that okay cut it off cut
it off all the way make sure it's all
the way gone and I think it's a pretty
nice clean layout
it needs a little spark but not a lot he
just needs one like little trick that's
all okay now we looked at this layout
noka looked at it and I played around
with a little bit this was all converted
to outlines because I know I don't have
this typeface on Durman so he was able
to convert it for me
but it makes it super hard for me to
work on top and I did the best that I
could and I started to reconstruct it
here I increased the lighting a little
bit the spacing got a little bit tight
here and in terms of some of this
information and I really just wanted to
build off this is a 90-degree axis here
and that's it and just bring up spacing
the journal for graphic design so I'm
doing very similar things to what Joshua
is doing Joshua Gilley but I'm just
using the information that you have and
if you start to look at the blocks of
words and you can squint your eyes
they're kind of like lines and so you
can make it work like that
okay I won't talk about this layout here
so this is a layout um Christina
Christina has had her work selected
multiple times here so I know I know
she's onto something
what's really cool about this is kind of
an isometric axial or how do you know
xeo metric perspective and there's
something cool it kind of bends down it
goes back up and then something weird
happens here it's like one one won't two
might three will three makes a pattern
and so you break your own pattern or by
going one two and right okay and I get
it so here's what I did I took this
whole layout and I reconstructed it and
turn it into like this oh I think then
Nate right and I just got rid of the has
is kind of South by South what is that
North by Northwest the Alfred Hitchcock
movie title with Saul Bass I believe and
it can you see this being kinetic guys
like sliding in 90 degrees and push
in and out of space another form of
rhythm that you're practicing here and
it's a rhythm of XY and Z the axis of XY
is a beautiful beautiful interpretation
solution and my kudos to Christina for
doing this this this is this is you're
pushing yourself you're trying to think
outside the box I actually do teach this
I do have a week in my course where it's
a 3d but I ask my students to create 3d
outside the box so what do I mean by
that is by taking the typography itself
wrap it around it boxes and then
photograph it and make it look like it
was done on the computer I think you can
also learn a lot from that as well if
you're interested but thank you for
trying this a good job yeah so a couple
other things there Christina the the
open letting and tracking is just it's
just eating up so much space and I think
let the resume be the star let it be
really dense and then everything else
chill out okay so you see very small
adjustments basically of closing a
colliding and the tracking and not
necessarily like why does features have
to be all caps I don't know Chris I
really like what you did with everything
but I'm still not resolved with the
features and the name of the artist I
don't know I would probably do open up
the tracking you like an open jacket yes
cuz cuz right now it's just sitting
there like a solo Island and then maybe
bring it all the way yeah let's see if
we can really bring it open it up even
more so it gets really close to February
not that close but uh-huh
nice job beautiful yeah yeah I like that
uh-oh oh my god gorgeous there's your
loft or does your crisscross beautiful
and now everything is working together
as a unit when I see that page to me it
tells me every element is working in
collaboration with one another yeah so
we just had different preferences
like I I personally don't like it so
much so that I wanted some space to kind
of breathe and let the white space flow
through but to each their own right so a
lot of different ways to solve this and
there's no one right answer you guys can
can try it many different ways and and
be successful at it okay so let me hide
this thing now I'm gonna go and to look
at this one here this is from
Christiansen I think these are multiple
layouts submitted by Christiansen two of
them nice very nice layout nice good job
good job
resonate really tight tracking and then
breaking it apart using the orientation
using this little bit of detail type in
here just kind of break it up and you
see you guys if you really look at this
you can see that there's really big
all-caps type and both and then really
small upper lowercase numerals and this
is a regular weight and the contrast
between the two makes the bold bolder
and the regular and it just really
pushes them apart which is really nice
I think that's working really well some
issues here at the bottom here but
whatever and then using the small and
big type together I forgot to mention I
forgot to mention here
Joshua Gilley you're using like
four-point type here it's kind of out of
bounds for me but I guess you're
treating its texture but just try to
work within the constraints and see if
you can still have that same harmonious
layout okay so I think it's really nice
layout yeah I agree that's a really nice
job Chris and Chris you're definitely
following all the rules brilliant
because this is where we want to get you
we want you guys to learn all the rules
and then what do we do with the rules
Masum yes brigham and that's when you
have fun that's when you know where to
go where not to go cuz you know the
rules
make sense yes the job Chris you keep
keep on going with your foot on the gas
pedal with design so I think this may be
another Chris layout here and I like
this originally I'm looking like wow
they're just like you know what I'm
picking multiple designs that you submit
it means you're doing something right or
really wrong but that either way it's
good and I can see what you're doing
here with the end
reversing out and then trying the L to
line up with that end it just creates a
really funny shape because my mind goes
like there's like a weird P letter now
with like a lowercase P there's
something funny so sometimes the
alignment works for you and sometimes it
works against you oh well they're eight
and I think's just kind of flowing
evenly uneven really nice things a
detail type up here so Noah do you want
to say anything about this I want to go
back to the other one cuz Moe is asking
why there's no trapped space no I'm not
sure if I understand your question
there's no trap space here because this
is because if you because I'm using my
mouse to show you where the tracks is
now you can see there's no trap space
here what what trap space are we talking
about the its flowing everything is
flowing you have trap space when you
have text here text here and text here
okay when you have text at three corners
we don't have text at three corners well
want to know we don't write Chris do you
see any trap space here that I'm going
to see what's that I do really know what
he's talking about here I think I think
most like why aren't you calling him out
for trapped space and I think he's
looking at this that's not trap space at
all because it's open to the right and
to the bottom if you put a text
vertically like let's say where that
little tiny text is what is it is the
date if you do bring that down then
you're trapping your space but if it's
but it's snuggling itself underneath the
letter Z so it's working together as a
unit not as a trap space please thank
you guys for asking this question so we
can clarify it for you guys I hope that
helps yeah so a simple thing mo if you
want to let more air or white space to
go through just rotate the type that's
what I did there I know I think because
we have such a strong vertical access
here this is so strong that he doesn't
need to be all the way through see he's
lined up the R and the end and all of
this against it so at this point you're
free to kind of open it
a little bit it doesn't have to be all
the way through and if that helps you
with your hold trap space I think most
struggling as many people do it's like
at one time it seems arbitrary that you
may say there's no space and it's
trapped in another moment it's like it's
not trapped and here's what you guys
need to realize is oftentimes the lay up
is just busted so we're gonna just call
out the most obvious things but as we
just literally said minutes ago once you
learn how to make the design work you
can break every rule that we told you
and still make it work yes from your
perspective you're like wait if I follow
that rule then this should not work so
Chris has found a way to make it work
and it's totally okay good job good job
all right thank you for asking good
questions folks all right there's a
couple of things I would do but we're
leave it alone so the one that I work on
is this one so before I show you what I
did no gun do you want to say what what
you would like to do to this what would
I like to do to it let's see I'm I'm
wondering about the space between the
names of the artists between that and
resonate I'm wondering about that space
I like the rhythm of it moving forward
in an italic motion I'm not sure if I
would have the word the four I would
probably play with that a little because
it's creating some kind of a rhythm and
somebody said that we can share a screen
and do point out and I'm not sure how if
anyone knows please do let us know so it
would be great to do that I know Tate I
could go to the go to the view options
let's see you you're muted Chris oh it
chris has to do that Chris you're muted
okay sorry yeah you could do it you you
can just hit annotate but you know I
think weird it's dangerous now for us to
be doing that because Noah's gonna do
and then then I can't get rid of it or
yeah it's just it'll be alright I know
exactly what she's talking about she's
talking about this space here
or okay milk we'll learn how to use ooh
and then we'll be all good okay no
worries there guys
yes sir you have some issues with this
and the four okay so I I took a stab at
it I like the layout I want to make sure
that that you understand that I do like
the layout I just started changing a
little bit I'm not done with it
but the thing that's bugging me is
generally speaking when you have to
invert things like this it's just
generally problematic for me for me and
I know you can make it work I just don't
like it and I'm playing around with it
so I'm not sure I made it any better but
I'm just trying to show you an
alternative to this trying to keep
within the same design principles and
the flow that you have here there's
probably still some issues here in terms
of space but maybe we delete some of it
I like how you built this file though
because the file is super efficient and
organized and so it's very easy for me
to make some changes otherwise it'd be a
nightmare
okay so so maybe that uses some of space
about I don't know that's just an idea
let's keep going okay what else do we
have here talked about those talk to it
it's okay this is from Brian Butler the
person who's a daddy I think right he's
back on this week really nice layup I
like this layout a lot it's very simple
and it's using you know there's there's
a lot that's going on but at the same
time it's not overwhelming me and I just
try to like see if I can just introduce
a little bit more white space without
change their layout and that's all I did
there I'm not saying it's a giant
improvement or anything we're talking
about like inches here a little
refinement but that's all can I give
kudos to Brian for one thing if I may
have to go to his original design please
Chris thank you so much
notice folks that everything is vertical
except 0 1 0 to 20 20 now remember I
remember in the earlier versions
former weeks we talked about hey folks
you can't have something be speaking one
direction and everything else another
direction because there's not talking to
one another but here is exactly where he
knows the rules and he's breaking it and
it's working why is it working I'm just
putting it out there so we can think
about it I don't want to give the
answers but I want to think about if you
don't tell us the answer I don't know
okay
well no we do again Chris you and I are
gonna are not gonna be there so I want
friends too and this is one way of
continuing to learn is by asking
yourself questions all the time the W
questions why why where why how what
okay ask those questions and then that's
how you find the solution so I'm asking
myself the same question hmm Milka
according to your rules everything is to
talking you know a sound direction if
they're not you know all in the same
direction and it's something else
another direction then it's speaking in
silo but here it's working why is that
maybe it's because it's very small and
maybe it's because it is very that the
width the length of the paragraph is
very short so it's mimicking this rows
of lines that are going vertical does
that make sense
yes so that's what I'm thinking because
if you look at the width of the of that
paragraph 0 1 0 2 20 20 is almost in the
same alignment and the same width as the
other paragraphs and it is acting
vertical it is not a straight line it is
acting vertically by doing hardship
about doing hard return harder to
actually solve it your self returns self
written so it is still speaking
vertically I need to know the answer
right now I'm deconstructing it in front
of you guys and that's how I'm coming up
with the answer it is not the only
horizontal element resonate is also so
maybe that's how
you - yes that's just centered and and
that is also me making the vertical
verticality by being doing the hard
return or the self return I should say
good job good job on that very nice
okay so what my other one another
comment here Brian is that I get it
there's blocks of copy but if you're not
familiar with these names especially she
gave or she Gail Fukuda it's like you
would not be able to decipher this so I
think some of it needs a little bit of
help some spacing some I just added some
periods in there just to make it a
little bit easier to read because I
don't want to work that hard to read it
all caps is hard to read no spacing
between first and last name even harder
so just help me out just a little bit
you can just put spaces if you want but
I don't think that destroys the design
intent okay okay real quick this is
Brian hey Brian what's up mate I was
just saying in the original design the
first and last name you're separated I
use bold for the first names and like
for the last name okay some of that
separation okay so this was bold so you
might run into a new problem now yeah
ain't your design become a piano effect
yeah
what you could do is take everything
reduce the size is making people but
then read it out check it out yeah
that'll be another serration yeah but
again folks you don't know until you try
it so even though Chris is asking you do
10 exercises if there's one particular
one like let's say this one do five
other versions so you can figure it out
figure out what works best and we don't
know till we try it out that's how we're
gonna learn yep
I just swim and just reminded because
Brian's on you guys I don't have
Helvetica black I do have heavy Etica
now black and extra black and bold and
all that kind of stuff I just don't have
Helvetica black so if you guys use that
it won't show up and then I have to
convert it so I just wanted you guys
know I also don't have haveta Kanoa I
think Linotype version and I wrote it so
I'm gonna show G in a second sorry that
I'm doing this guys but I want to get
back to the design intent that Brian had
why Chris is doing that may I please
encourage everyone to check out every
one of these artists especially Wolfgang
Winegard for next week why because
Wolfgang weingartz is the master of
lines check out his work he has a big
fat book if you guys go to the library
you might be able to find it I have a
copy of it here in that late but go
check out his book check out his work
there's a lot of his stuff is online I'm
sure and you be very inspired by how he
uses lines and I think that will be a
good inspiration for you for next week's
assignment
okay so whoo look at that right Chris do
you agree oh yes yes yes of course give
me one second here so if you guys are
using Helvetica I think this is Linotype
standard or something I don't know LTS d
a couple of you guys are using this
typeface I dunno
had this our place I'm not trying to buy
another cut of Helvetica please just use
standard Helvetica or Helvetica neue
which is this and I don't have heavy
okay so if you guys are using these
typefaces it's gonna come up as garbage
and you may be wondering why is why
aren't I critiquing your work there's a
good reason because I can't open the
files and they all it's all garbage and
I don't have time to like go and convert
every single one of them so the
alternative is to outline it but then I
can't edit it so that's what happens
there okay we're gonna move on but those
are the two typefaces I do not have
please I do not have these I'm gonna
zoom in and zoom I do not have these two
typefaces this wait I have Helvetica but
I don't have heavy and then I don't have
this one all right okay so here it's
Boldin and regular I think he said bold
and light and just to save me some
trouble I don't want to go through and
do that too okay so that's it so this is
the one modification I made to it you
can use all that weight all right very
powerful very powerful beautiful good
job good job
okay here we go this is from Kevin
Portillo and nice layout very simple
very clean just tighten it up a little
bit for me just for me and this is what
I did to it so you guys can see the
before and then after
yeah could we could we talk about this
for a second Chrissa views are beautiful
zoom at the liver so we can see both
pages please cuz right uh-huh
folks let's take a look at the left and
take a look at the right they're almost
identical but what did Chris do here
what did he do that made it look like
it's ready to go out there on the runway
and show itself off do you see that it
has that look and fill so look at it
analyze that ask yourself questions and
then that's how you learn because Chris
and I we can talk about these things so
the cows come home but it is with you
using your eyes comparing and
contrasting and asking questions that
you're able to learn the difference
between something that is good and
something that is even better
I like that Kevin had broken apart
rosemary T C and C free goat
because odermatt and TC they're known as
this design power team but that's two
people combined into one and so by
breaking their part we actually add an
extra block of information which is nice
and I and it makes for a nicer three
column layout versus however this is
divided up I just did I didn't make a
whole lot of changes to it as you can
see just some very small tweaks and then
just like let it relax so as we're
looking at a lot of experimental layouts
I don't want you guys get confused that
the only critiques are the ones where
it's going bananas and so next week you
guys go nutso on us that's not it at all
there are layouts that are very
functional that are good that aren't
worth repeating and this as week five so
that's why I just want to make a little
tweak here to say that I still do
appreciate very beautifully subtly
design layouts that you don't have to go
that's so honest okay job everyone good
job nice work everyone this week was
really good okay I think where we got
most of them maybe there's a couple more
in here
can we talk about yes I think that's
this one's your favorite Chris it is
[Laughter]
it's got your signature on it it's got
typing motion mm-hmm but frozen yeah but
you can see that there's some funkiness
going on that in order to get this type
to read in case you guys I want to do
this if you if you look at the preview
the outline mode is actually really cool
I love this this is actually probably
cooler layout so when you give when you
guys can use boxes next week with lines
this might be a very interesting way to
design to draw the boxes around the
shapes and then allow that to become
part of the visual language I find that
it's odd that this is more pleasing to
me than this is yeah so you knew how to
design here and then you'd start
tweaking everything I was like it got a
little crazy but those of you guys that
are not that familiar with illustrator
if I select this type and I go to window
and I bring up the appearance panel
you'll see that
for who did this but this person added a
3d rotate a transform and this is how
you're able to create these effects
right so if you if you add the 3d rotate
it does that and then if you have to
transform it as that you turn this off
it does some pretty cool things and you
can create some really wild trippy
things but this thing if you go back
into regional settings here and you take
away the stroke it changes it but nice
you know I like this better except for
the fact that I can't read it that's the
only problem okay so I think in here I
think it's is it here no it's maybe it's
here somewhere near he was able to
repeat this and I forgot how to do it
but okay so I'm gonna do all this play
back to normal thank you for sharing
that with us Chris I don't think we can
do that in InDesign I may have to look
into that but that's so cool they can do
it in Illustrator yeah you could do some
pretty trippy things that speaking of
trippy things here's another one
why's this gone away I said go okay
Nikki Nikki Robyn apostille some crazy
stuff going on there you think Nikki was
inspired by the resonate and making it
kind of reverberate a little bit
visually and I think Nikki was pretty
successful at creating this echoing
effect and what she did was to take the
word and then the mask it and scale it
down I keep doing that I think I think
that's how this is created or maybe not
but it creates a really weird shape it's
very powerful what do you think oh um I
think I really like Nikki trying to do
these really cool brilliant creative
ideas now that we've put everything
together I want to push Nikki to put
that energy into how to create depth by
using different sizes and different
weights and you can use different sizes
in different ways without repeating and
create depth with hierarchy of
information
we want to make sure that you have that
under your belt before you go anywhere
else again my kudos to you for trying to
side good job good job
that this goes to show you're very
creative you want to do creative things
but at the same token this is a
typography class and I'd list for sure
from unlined behalf and I know it's for
on behalf of Chris as well we want to
make sure you learn the elements first
before you go on as I said putting
makeup on you can keep talking oh just
okay keep talking so it I'm looking at
look as I'm looking I'm noticing that
you're using upper case they're all
upper case almost all of them they're
all upper case yeah so Nikki do yourself
a favor
go back and take this layout and ask
yourself if I had to yes you had to
inject three different sizes and three
different weights how would you solve
this layout in terms of the hierarchy of
typography from the readability what's
the first rate second read and third I
want to challenge everyone on this get
this under your belt folks because if
you don't get that on your belt
then you're running around like a
chicken with no head exactly the sound
of a chicken with its head cut off how
would you do that
not that that's something else and I'm
pushing you folks because I really care
about you that you really understand the
fundamentals of typography and again the
fundamentals of typography aligns with
the fundamentals and the principles of
design which is one of them is contrast
contrast space we're talking about that
every week I know it's becoming a
repetition for
you guys contrast of positions you many
of you guys are using it good job we've
talked about that contrast of form we
saw some of those layouts had they were
broken up good job with doing that and
and it's next to a whole contrast of we
talked about position isolation grouping
contrast of structure we talked about
organized versus chaos maybe this is
where we're dealing with we're dealing
with chaos and organization here with
Nikki's layout we're also dealing with
contrast of size but in more of a
contrast I want to see more of depth
between sizes and different weights and
of course when you guys when we start
moving into experimental we're dealing
with contrast of texture how do you
create density how do you create
roughness sharp smoothness and all that
so be aware of all these things friends
and you can check out elements and
principles of design there's a lot of
the map there and and take a good look
and then ask yourself if you're
implementing any of them hope that's
helpful to everyone yes thank you very
much and now let's back to chris's
masterpiece well I don't know about that
but I'm trying to work with this idea of
the resonate and echoing it out like
that so I just took one thing and I cut
it and that's kind of where I'm at right
now
because it's kind of like a strong all
up case horizontal block information
it's going to start to dominate your
page so we're gonna need to like include
some things that are a little less heavy
maybe I was experimenting with how we
might be able to cut this perhaps and to
complete these two things coming
together I'm not quite sure yeah I feel
like I need something here let me just
grab this one nice thing about the way
that you've prepared your files is it's
at a 45 degree angle which makes it very
easy for me to grab and pull and move
things around okay so so maybe it's like
Mary I don't know we take this
from today back maybe it can be a layout
I'm not sure make sure those things are
lined up and you start to work on this
because I need some little elements
probably up here so what I'll do is I'll
just draw a box because I don't want to
sit here and work on this whole time
right and maybe you need something here
look at that starts to come together
right it's it's a little bit even on the
page here so maybe we try it moving in
to the left maybe maybe it's around he
we line everything up so the problem I
have with this original layout is this
it's like there's a giant ball shape
here so look let me get my brush here
I switched the ink color like a red or
something we have this giant ball shape
and then we have these things here and
they don't really talk to each other
like what's going on right and it's
because it's such a dominant object it's
like there's really no room for anything
else to happen so this is where you take
your idea like I really want to make
this work
pull it back get that thing to work and
then you can start to bring in other
components and make it all come together
okay Nikki that's that's the feedback
there Nikki can I share a thought with
you is that I don't know why when I see
your work the the video the music video
of wrecking ball comes into my head
you're talking about Miley Cyrus yes the
wrecking ball yes the music video of the
wrecking ball so if this was the poster
for that music video dude you're on
target so again you know typography the
power of good design speaks to the
intention as well so if that's your
intention then you're on the right track
so Nikki just left but she said thank
you for everything on this Thank You
Marc nice
very nice and folks the only thing I
like to say it Chris's is Eric as you're
doing this yeah of course is that it's
our job as designers to educate others
and what I mean by others means our
clients they don't know it's us that we
need to teach them or or share the
information with them and guide them so
as you're doing these exercises you
building confidence you're building
about how to become a good type or how
to create good layout with typography
using the power of good design and then
once you have that then you can go in
there and educate your clients and
persuade them to go with I don't know
with your crazy ing the ink design
layout that Chris was inspired by okay
so I think where we're coming up on two
hours that we need to wrap this up I
just wanted to mention something about
Lara's layout here is it's kind of like
using this type and it's getting smaller
and smaller
it's very illustrative it's treating the
mast-head like that you know if it
weren't the masthead maybe it'd be okay
and I drew the shape on top of it just
to show you guys it's you know it's not
a great layout if you were just to block
out their shapes here just look at the
shape size that is where it kills you
that is one of the elements that you can
trap space not kill you kill the kills
work so mode the answer to your question
if you want to create a trap space
that's it
that's how you create a trap space you
know the funny thing is for next week I
was like experiment I was drawing this
something the serendipity is the kind of
like where interesting things can happen
I think you could create something very
interesting if you hadn't just done
these on all bunch of different sizes
there's ways to make this work there
really is you don't need to do that okay
so I think we've looked at most of
everything there's another one here it's
a very similar kind of concept where you
have a lot of type using to point sizes
there I
believe you're way below the point size
limit the legal limit so to speak let's
say yeah I came in select okay so
Lindsey I'd love to be able to get into
your layout but I think it's already
been outlined because I I don't have the
typeface that you're using so it another
one of those cases so if you guys can
just use the more standard version how
about okay here's the thing you don't
have to have fancy Helvetica you just
need Helvetica with light irregular and
bold you don't even need oblique and
you're good to go
don't use the typeface as a crutch some
of you guys you're using the very kind
of extreme ends of the weights like
ultra thin or ultra light and extra
black you don't need all that massimo
McNelly didn't need it you don't need it
either you can make it work okay
those are the extra makeup yeah it's a
little bit too much Jun's layout here
nice layout yes she is getting creative
here with all this kind of overlapping
good job yeah so I like it
logo here yeah the only thing for me is
like how do these things all talk to
each other
yep that's it just work that part out
yeah dude I I'm so sorry to interrupt
you okay should I encourage you both
Juna and and the former design is to
take that layout and do one more version
of it where yeah as Chris said they're
talking to one another there's more of a
unification this is a very nice clean
layout very organized they're all very
respectful to one another but then ask
yourself what else can I do with what I
have because you have the ingredients
you have their salt you have the pepper
you have the paprika we have the garlic
figure out how it needs to be simmered
so they taste really good together yes
ompletely assets you have great elements
you gotta figure out how to bring them
together to medley you know so that the
the flavors complement one another and
you don't quite do that just yet I think
if you were to follow mochas suggestion
of doing one more at least one more
version of this maybe it'll start to
work I'm not sure you know get it to
come together all right yeah it's time
for lunch
[Laughter]
okay I think that's it guys let's wrap
this up let me stop my share here let's
open it up to the group here final
thoughts and any enough thinking I'm
gonna apply this next week well before
we do that I don't know I just said that
before I do that let me just everybody
next week is week six and it pretty much
all the the constraints are lifted from
you and I'll be surprised to see who's
been able to apply the foundational
design principles moving forward next
week you use any point size you can use
any weight and you can now add in lines
or rules and shapes shapes are big
really fat lines basically so now you
can add all kinds of things I'm gonna
give you a little bit of caution
last time when I did this when people
are allowed to use shapes they forgot
that there's typography and they just
created shapes so they're really letting
their inner illustrator out think of the
shapes and how they aid in hierarchy and
how they group things together yes
No they create focal points don't just
start illustrating with shapes all over
the place and inevitably this is gonna
happen people are going to start
illustrating like that and we get away
from the typography we get into
illustration at that point ask yourself
a good point Chris ask yourself how
these lines that you're implementing
there are they are adding more depth and
more hierarchy to what you want to be
read first second and third again look
at some of these designers that we have
in the list specially Wolfgang to see
how he used lines to create his layout
the other thing for line is line is used
for categorization or organization okay
so ask yourself how can I use lines to
organize and categorize information so
those of you who are really good at
organizing you might really thrive on
this exercise okay that's it for us for
the live stream alka stay on for a
little bit and talk to the people who
are tuned in live via our zoom call
today that's it we will see you guys
next week on Tuesday that's it for me
and for the rest of team okay thank you
very much for doing this with us once
thank you thank you for having me
pleasure bye everybody